bonjour à tous ce matin les sénateurs
poursuivent l'examen du projet de loi
sur l'avenir de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation et de la forêt ce texte
qui a été adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale au mois de janvier est examiné
en première lecture par le Sénat ce
texte vise essentiellement à verdir
l'agriculture à promou voir
l'agroécologie par la mise en place de
groupements d'intérêt économique et
environnemental des groupements qui
rassemblent les agriculteurs aux bonnes
pratique et ces derniers en échange
reçoivent des aides préférentielles hier
les sénateurs ont achevé la discussion
générale puis lors de l'examen de
l'article 1er ils ont réaffirmé la
nécessité de protéger les pâturages du
loup après cela ils ont examiné tous les
articles concernant l'outre maire appelé
en priorité ce matin ils reprennent
l'examen à l'article 4 article qui
modifie le code de l'environnement pour
mieux encadrer l'utilisation de
fertilisants dans les zones atteintes
par la pollution tout de suite on prend
la direction de l'hémicycle l'ordre du
jour appelle la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale d'avenir pour l'agriculture
l'alimentation et la forêt dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes
parvenus à l'article 4 article 4 j'ai
une demande de parole de Marcel den vous
avez la parole chers
collègu madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lorsque
j'avais demandé un temps de parole sur
cet article 4
j'avais deux observations à faire sur
cet article 4 l'une d'elles me paraît
être inutile puisque sur l'aspect du
bail environnemental il me semble qu'on
a trouvé un consensus ce qui me permet
d'ajouter mes compliments à ceux qui ont
déjà été faits hier sur les qualités de
consensus du rapporteur et et du
président que je veux à mon tour
féliciter lui j'ai une deuxième
observation sur ces problèmes de l'azote
monsieur le
ministre une observation puis une
suggestion on ne peut pas traiter de la
même manière quand on parle de l'azote
l'azote organique et l'azote minéral
c'est des problèmes techniques mais il
faut quand même le dire à ceux qui sont
chargés d'appliquer la réglementation
c'est pas la même chose ça n'a pas les
mêmes répercussions sur la qualité du
sol donc première observation ma seconde
observation j'ai fait un rapport en 2001
sur les variations climatique à cette
époque j'avais interrogé le président de
l'Académie de médecine le professeur
Tubiana qui est maintenant décédé et le
professeur Tubiana m'avait dit sa
perplexité sur la manière dont il
fallait apprécier ce CIFRE de 50 mg qui
n'avait aucune justification médicale
c'était il y a 14 ans ça n'a pas changé
je veux vous le redire ce n'est pas un
dogme c'est un chiffre qui est là un peu
par hasard il faut donc le manier avec
beaucoup de précaution je le dis surtout
pour mes amis qui s'en servent parfois
comme du vérité médicale ce n'est pas
vrai mon deuxième point c'est de vous
parler monsieur le ministre de la
manière d'apprécier ce critère sur la
pente en matière
d'azote j'ai cultivé des terres en pente
et lorsqu'on cultivait des terres en
pente avec la tracction animale on la
Bourit dans un sens perpendiculaire à la
pente parce qu'on n'ait pas la puissance
pour laabourer dans le sens montant
descendant les attelages le permettaient
pas et leur rellement voir l'érosion qui
est consécutif au labour du sens de la
pente et le résultat de la
mécanisation lorsqu'on a un tracteur
important si on labour en travers le
conducteur n'est pas à le matériel
travaille mal bon donc c'est le résultat
de la mécanisation or en labourant en
montant descendant on pratique toutes
les 35 ou 40 cm suivant le matériel
qu'on emploie une rigole qui permet à
l'eau de dégourliner d'un boutalote de
la pente or il y a un moyen d'arrêter
cette ce phénomène qui a été créé par la
mécanisation et qui est irréversible
puisque la mécanisation continuera on va
pas revenir à l'attraction animale il y
a un moyen d'arrêter ça s'appelle la
culture sans labour dans le département
de la Somme d'où je viens nous avons
beaucoup insister pour créer des des
cultures sans labour qui est une bonne
réponse agronomique une bonne réponse
environnementale avec l'économie
d'énergie et j'ai maintenant dans le
département de laassum plus de 10000
hectares cultivés sans labour or on ne
peut pas apporter la même réponse sur
les terres en pente et sur le
pourcentage de pente aux gens qui
cultivent sans labour ou à ceux qui
cultivent suivant d'autres méthodes je
souhaite donc monsieur le ministre
qu'avec vos services qui sont capables
de le faire vous avez une très forte
compétence dans tous vos services on
réfléchisse à la manière de donner un
signal pour que cette technique de
culture sans labour qui est utile et
nécessaire se développe à condition que
l'interprétation qu'on fera des textes
leur donne un signal favorable alors je
voulais vous le signaler nous sommes pas
pressés mais nous attendons ce signal
quelque part pour continuer à développer
la culture sans
labour merci chers collègues je suis
saisie de quatre amendements faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 324
rectifié bis ah Monsieur le
Ministre oui je vrais quand même
commencer cette matinée avec quelques
petits mots sur les grands enjeux
agronomiques et je salue l'intervention
du sénateur deu par rapport à toutes ces
questions qui qui sont liés j'ai vu
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'amendements qui
se posent un certain nombre de questions
et je reprends deux trois sujets
importants la question de l'azot et en
particulier sur la question de la
déclaration sur les ventes d'azote
minéral il faut quand même qu'on
s'explique de manière très claire sur ce
sujet j'ai entendu hier déjà que c'était
un élément de complication
supplémentaire je rappelle quel est
l'objectif et pourquoi en Bretagne par
exemple c'est à accepté par la
profession
agricole toute la profession
agricole à l'échelle de la Chambre
d'Agriculture régionale et par les
syndicats agricoles j'ai bien dit les
syndicats agricoles quel est l'objectif
de cette déclaration d'azote minéral qui
ne concerne pas les
agriculteurs mais les distributeurs
d'azote et qui se met en place à titre
expérimental après décision au niveau de
la
région la Bretagne étant la première
région qui va expérimenter cette
mesure je rappelle il s'agit de
substituer à l'azote minéral qui est
acheté aujourd'hui et épendu sur les
terres en Bretagne l'excédent d'azote
organique qui est lié à la à l'élevage
breton principe
simple je vous rappelle en plus que
l'azote c'est du
gaz et on
importe ce gaz et donc cet azote alors
qu'on a de l'excédent d'azote organique
qui souvent au lieu d'aller fertiliser
les terres et les plantes va dans les
rivières et ensuite faire ce qu'on sait
c'est-à-dire des algues vertes donc le
principe c'est de se mettre en ordre de
bataille pour substituer à l'azote
minéral acheté et importé qui coûte cher
l'azote organique en excédent mais pour
arriver à faire ça il faut qu'on soit
capable de savoir combien il y avait
d'azote minéral de vendu les
agriculteurs ça ne change rien pour eux
c'est les distributeurs et les vendeurs
d'azote qui devront déclarer les
quantités qu'ils ont vendu dans une
année de référence qui sera l'année 2000
2014 et puis après on calculera la
substitution la baisse de l'azote
minéral et c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin
d'une déclaration donc faut pas se
tromper dans ce
débat je le dis vraiment à tous les
sénateurs qui ont que j'ai entendu hier
ou même dans les amendements que j'ai vu
laisse penser que cette déclaration ça
serait encore une norme supplémentaire
non c'est un objectif extrêmement clair
qui va permettre d'utiliser l'azote
organique qui
est produit ici plutôt que d'importer de
l'azote minéral voilà le sujet de la
même manière sur la question de la
méthanisation qu'est-ce que c'est que la
méthanisation
il y a un rapport de l'adè je le dis
quand même ici ce matin un rapport de
l'adè qui indique que si on valorisait
l'ensemble du méthane lié à la
production de matière organique
aujourd'hui en France on arriverait on
arriverait à produire en méthane dans le
réseau près de 40 % de ce qu'on consomme
aujourd'hui en
gaz et je le répète gaz importé et vous
savez de quelle région le sud ou
quelquefois de l'Est avec les sujets Gé
politiqu géostratégique qui vont avec là
on a un potentiel de gaz j'allais dire
naturel je vais ça entre guillemets qui
est là et on ne le valorise pas dans le
système de l'azote total avec derrière
la méthanisation c'est le fameux plan
Mama qui est en cours de mise en œuvre
c'est ça l'objectif aussi c'est de faire
en sorte que ce qui est un déchet
aujourd'hui
devienne une
ressource et l'agriculture a une
potentialité il s'agit pas de substituer
la production de gaz le méthane à une
production agricole il s'agit de faire
en sorte que la production agricole qui
génère de la matière organique puisse
valoriser cette matière organique au
travers du méthane pour faire du gaz
c'est ça l'objectif aussi on est
parfaitement dans l'idée d'économie
circulaire et donc on a des
simplifications à faire parce que ça ça
m'a été posé comme question il y a plein
de projets mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
toujours des difficultés simplifier les
procédures c'est engagé c'est la
procédure unique de déclaration que ça
soit l'éolien que ça soit le solaire que
ça soit le méthane on a une seule
déclaration à faire et pas trois
établissement classés tout un tas de
problèmes à gérer c'est engagé à titre
expérimental pour les 3 années qui
viennent on va accélérer ce processus il
y a aussi des questions sur les prix de
rachat hein et la dégressivité par
exemple lorsqu'on fait des systèmes
collectifs qui finissent par remettre en
cause on avait le débat hier les
systèmes collectifs au détriment des
systèmes individuels et qui surtout
pourrait si on ne peut pas développer de
manière plus structurante les systèmes
collectifs faire que un certain nombre
d'exploitations de taille moyenne n'est
pas accès à la méthanisation parce
qu'ils auraient pas les capacités de
financer des projets collectifs au
travers de la dégressivité en
particulier du prix de rachat donc on a
plein de sujets sur lesquels il faut
qu'on continue de travailler sur les
déclarations sur les IPE aussi mais ayez
conscience dans l'esprit de cette loi
qu'on est dans un processus qui va dans
le sens d'enclencher une capacité à
l'agriculture de pouvoir valoriser ce
qui était considéré comme des déchets
aujourd'hui comme des ressource ce qui
sur la question de l'azote consiste à
dire tout simplement que plutôt que
d'importer de l'azote minéral et du gaz
et bien utilisons mieux et de manière
plus rationnelle l'azote organique qui
est disponible lorsqu'il est en excédent
c'est ça aussi le principe et puis sur
les grandes questions agronomiqu qui ont
été évoqué par Monsieur denu c'est
d'accompagner tout ça avec des modèles
agronomiques qui permettent juste
justement de mieux absorber l'azote de
mieux le garder de mieux le séquestrer
dans les sols et de mieux le délivrer
ensuite pour les plantes plutôt que de
l'utiliser en épandage qui souvent finit
dans les rivières ou ailleurs c'est ça
l'objectif voilà je voulais le rappeler
au moment où on va discuter beaucoup
d'amendements ne nous trompons pas il y
a pas plus de normees il y a simplement
un changement de modèle et
d'approche merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur revet c'est sur article c'est
sur l'article c'est une parole sur
l'article alors je vous en prie allez-y
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues de mots
parce que il y a encore je sais plus
combien aès de 700 amendements et on est
vendredi mais monsieur ministre très
bien ce que vous venez dire on partage
tout à fait mais on fait comment je veux
dire par là il faut le dire
ici on le partage et pour celles et ceux
qui sur le terrain le pratiqu on est un
certain nombre euh de d'agriculteurs ou
d'anciens agriculteurs ici on partage le
principe monsieur le ministre mais après
qu'est-ce que l'ont fait je vous
rappelle que la France était le
principal producteur agricole en matière
de viande de lait et autres euh de
l'Europe il y a encore 10 15 ou 20 ans
et aujourd'hui les Allemands ont pris
nous ont remplacé et alors que nous leur
vendions du lait nous leur vendions de
la viande de porc et autres aujourd'hui
ce sont eux qui nous le vendent pourquoi
pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre si vous
voulez bien m'écouter 30 secondes tout
simplement parce que la politique
agricole en Allemagne a été complètement
changée et à l'image j'entends encore
mon collègue Gérard bailli dire
s'agissant des agneaux qui venant de
Nouvelle-Zélande que la valeur ajoutée
la valeur là-bas c'était la laine et non
pas la viande et que nous vendait la
viande d'agneau à à bas prix et donc
concurrençait nos agneaux et bien là
c'est c'est la même chose le production
de méthane en Allemagne a fait en sorte
que les coûts de production de du lait
et de la viande en laemagne ont diminué
fortement et qu'il nous concurrence
alors chiche je crois que les
agriculteurs sont prêts je suis pas
breton je suis normand mais ils sont
prêts à faire mais pardel là le discours
parce que c'est bien de de dire le
discours monsieur le ministre il y a des
amis qui vont le reprendre qui sont dans
cette himicycle ou autre pour encore
fusiller les agriculteurs mais alors
mettons au point dans un accord entre
les élus les responsables et et les
professionnels un dispositif qui fasse
que on puisse permettre à nos
agriculteurs de réaliser ce que vous
faites mais il va falloir les aider
comme les Allemands les les l'Allemagne
a aider ses
producteurs merci chers collègues
l'amendement 324 rectifi bis monsieur
César vous le
présentez madame la Présidente j'ai bien
entendu le plaidoyer du ministre par
rapport donc à ces zones il faut lui
rendre hommage parce que c'est ça
concerne uniquement les zones
vulnérables c'est ce qui est écrit dans
le texte hein et ça ça me paraît
important de souligner mais après il est
dit il est dit l'autorité administrative
peut imposer aux personnes qui
détiennent à titre professionnel des
matières fertilisantes à ajouter à cette
zone y compris aux transporteurs de ces
matières une déclaration annuelle
relative aux quantités d'azote qu'ils
ont traité reçu livré cédé à T gratuit
ou onéreux dans la zone où qu'ils ont
cédé à toute personne qui expédie ou
livre dans cette zone les matières
fertilisantes azoté donc aujourd'hui
notre amendement 324 a pour objectif
donc de supprimer les alinéas de 1 à 6
et moins de contraintte Monsieur le
Ministre moins de normes moins de et
nous sommes à l'époque où on veut
simplifier l'administration de la France
et en hom complexifie encore plus donc
nous sommes opposés à à cette solution
qui n'est pas bonne dans l'article
4 le 379 rectifié le 518 rectifié sont
identiques monsieur Collin avez-vous
quelques chose à rajouter ou je peux
considérer qu'il est défendu il est
défendu je vous remercie Monsieur L
monsieur
laasser non ne perdons pas de temps
c'est le c'est c'est le même amendement
transposons-nous dans la réalité des
pratiques nous avons l'absolu ti en
zones vulnérable cet amendement ne
touche ce texte ne touche que les zones
vulnérables ok il faut y faire des
efforts on a la garantie que les
agriculteurs ont
l'obligation de déclarer la totalité de
leurs apports azotés qu'il soient
chimique ou qu'il soient d'autres
origines animal notamment je ne sais pas
si vous vous rendez compte de la
complexité inutile que l'on rajoute aux
pratiques normales on est dans une
période recherche de la simplification
administrative nous avons là un tout
petit endroit hein où il serait facile
de ne pas alourdir de ne pas va
compliquer imaginons un instant
également dans ces zones dites fragiles
la loi l'autorisant toutes les
tentatives qu'il y aura de la faire
appliquer alors moi je suis très étonné
que l'on complique à souet un problème
qui est
réglé merci Monsieur lasser le 240
rectifier bis monsieur Deneu vous pouvez
le
défendre il est
défendu
non mais monsieur deu peut le
défendre madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre il s'agit d'ajouter à
l'alinéa 5 après les mots ces matières
les mots et ou au prestataire de
servicees dépendage en effet ces
services dépendages jouent un rôle non
négligeable et il joueront de plus en
plus dans la mesure où il s'agit
d'entreprises spécialisées par
lesquelles nous avons de plus en plus de
besoins pour des travaux spécialisés je
vous remercie chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur l'avis de la commission
sur les trois amendements identiques
donc un avis et sur le 240 rectifi
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues bonjour
nous démarrons la la journée par un
sujet très
important d'abord dans le dans la loi il
est bien indiqué mais ça a été dit par
Monsieur César et par Monsieur lasser
c'est dans les zones vulnérabl donc déjà
en levant tous les faux débats tout le
reste zone vulnérable mais s'il y a ça
pour les zones
vulnérable c'est bien que on part de
quelque chose et c'est bien qu'il a eu
une une façon d'appréhender cette
agriculture et les pendages d'azote
depuis 30 ans qui a fait que nous avons
pollué les sols ça c'est une réalité et
aujourd'hui personne ne sait quelle
conséquence cela peut avoir sur la santé
et sur l'environnement mais surtout sur
la santé de l'homme aucune étude
sérieuse n'a été faite sur les polluants
en faible dose en mélange et dans la
durée personne personne ni ceux qui sont
pour ni ceux qui sont contre c'est la
raison pour laquelle je fais ma première
pub de la journée dans la
drrome va être construit un pôle de
recherche en toxicologie
environnementale et en
écotoxicologie unique unique en Europe
validé par l'État validé par toutes les
universités validé par les pôles de
recherche mondiaux pour savoir si oui ou
non nous en parlions hier avec Madame
Blandin le principe de précaution soit
d'un côté ne s'arente pas pousser au
bout à de l'obscurantisme soit de
l'autre côté on dit que ça ne sert à
rien et bien il faut objectiver le
principe de précaution mais il y a une
chose dont on est sûr c'est que
lespendag qu'il a eu pendant toutes ces
années toute l'azote qui a été dans les
sols a fait très mal et je dirais à
Monsieur revet que nous sommes tous sur
le
terrain moi je ne suis pas agriculteur
mais je prétends connaître un peu
l'agriculture dans mon territoire et il
y a aussi des zones des zones des des
pendages et si la polique la politique
agricole allemande a changé ben c'est
bien pour ça que le ministre aujourd'hui
avec cette loi d'avenir veut la changer
parce qu'on se compare toujours à
l'Allemagne mais enfin si on a quelques
difficultés aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
bien sans aucun esprit polémique que la
politique agricole française menée
depuis ces dernières années n'a pas
forcément très bien marché
parce que si elle avait bien marché on
aurait pas entendu depuis 3 jours
problème de revenu problème de déprise
et cetera et tout ce qu'on voit dans
cette loi donc la loi qui est mis en
place par le par le ministre le fol
c'est justement pour essayer de régler
un ce nom de problème et puis après
Stéphane Lefol de la même couleur
politique ou d'une alternance il y aura
sûrement un autre ministre de
l'Agriculture qui fera une qui fera une
autre loi mais enfin nous l'évoquions
dans la discussion générale la LMAP que
nous avons débattu en 2009 c'est pas
loin 2009 elle avait des points très
positifs mais sur tous ces sujets elle
n'a rien amené et si nous sommes obligés
d'en parler aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
n'a rien amené donc sur ces sujets il
faut bien il faut bien euh il faut bien
avancer et puis vous parliez des aides
pour les agriculteurs je pense quand
même que avec la PAC avec la politique
menée par le chef de l'État et le et le
ministre nous sommes arrivés quand même
dans cette dans cette direction à a
sauveré ce dont on pensait qu'il n'était
pas sauvable alors c'est sûrement pas
assez pour les uns c'est bien pour les
autres on n'est là pas là pour
polémiquer mais je parler d'un constat
alors ensuite sur la suppression de
déclaration de obligatoire de flux
d'azote moi je pense et Monsieur Daniel
Dubois hier a fait voter un amendement
sur les normes sur la il y a un moment
où il y en a marre il y en a marre des
normes faut pas en rajouter sans cesse
sans cesse sans cesse mais enfin mais
enfin il y a norme et norme quand même
et ça ce qui est mis dans cette dans
cette dans cette loi sur le sur la
déclaration obligatoire c'est bien quand
même pour essayer de faire en sorte que
ça les choses ne s'empirent pas et c'est
pas un procès d'intention on sait très
bien tout le monde tout le monde essaye
de faire le mieux possible pour les
agriculteurs vous avez raison monsieur
lasser monsieur César ils font déjà leur
déclaration c'est pas la peine d'
rajouter c'est pour ça que ce qui est
dit dans la loi on n'en rajoute pas ils
font déjà leur leur déclaration donc il
y a pas de sujet là-dessus et on ne
complique pas pour les pour les
agriculteurs ce qui semble vous poser
problème c'est sur les transporteurs
voilà et nous en avons beaucoup parlé en
commission et nous en parlons encore en
apparté avec le président Raoul et on se
disait mais après tout si nous étions
des gens concrets pragmatiques comme
vous dites si on enlevait du texte
transporteurs et distributeur est-ce que
ça serait pas mieux ben non je suis
désolé de vous dire que ça ne serait pas
mieux parce que si on avait pu le faire
vous connaissez Danel Raoul il l'aurait
proposé et nous l'aurions fait pourquoi
c'est pas possible pourquoi c'est pas
possible parce que si on enlève mais je
sais qu'on n pas d'accord monsieur mais
si on enlève les transporteurs non mais
non mais c'est pas un contrôle encore si
on enlève je vais vous dire pourquoi si
on enlève les transporteurs alors là
vous pourrez dire qu'il y a de la
discrimination positive et négative ça
voudrait dire que seuls les agriculteurs
sont obligés de faire une déclaration
d'azote et les transporteurs ne seraient
pas obligés et quand une un G quand une
structure va chercher de l'azote à tel
endroit et l'amène dans sa structure
c'est quand même bien normal que le
transporteur là c'est pas une norme pour
les agriculteurs c'est pour que les
transporteurs le déclarent alors après
soit on se dit c'est bien pour la santé
c'est bien pour l'environnement c'est
bien pour faire pour contrôler cela
parce que le mot contrôle il a pas
forcément des des connotations toujours
négatives on veut améliorer les choses
soit on se dit on veut pas les contrôles
pour les transporteurs les distributeurs
ça veut dire peut-être je dis pas pas
pour vous hein surtout pas pour vous
aucun procès d'intention mais ça veut
dire peut-être que finalement on préfère
que rien ne soit contrôlé sur le sujet
et puis que l'on fasse comme avant et je
pense vraiment que si nous faisions
comme avant alors nous ne serions pas
responsabl vis-à-vis du Grenel dans
l'environnement et vis-à-vis de la santé
de nos petits-enfants c'est la raison
pour laquelle je crois vraiment que dans
les zones vulnérables uniquement
vulnérable déclaration annuelle pour les
agriculteurs très bien rajouter les
transporteurs et les distributeur c'est
pas un contrôle supplémentaire ça permet
tout simplement une vérification de la
situation de l'azote dans ces zones
vulnérables et voir si les choses se
passent plutôt bien je pense franchement
que il faut pas voir réglementation
énorme toujours de façon négative vous
savez ce que j'en pense il faut les
diminuer mais sur le sujet je crois
qu'il en va de la santé de l'homme et en
va de la santé des sols et de
l'environnement c'est pas un contrôle
supplémentaire c'est une vérification
objective de la situation monsieur le
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai pas entendu votre
avis alors vous aurez compris que je
mettais un avis défavorable à la
suppressionable le 240 rectifié bis
également monsieur le
rapporteur attendez là j'ai mal démarré
je me suis laissé qu'est-ce que vous
dites madame la Présidente
2 le le 240 rectifi B je mets un avis
favorable à l'amendement de Monsieur adà
j'ai bien fait de vous le demander
monsieur
ministre sur cette question de l'azote
et par rapport aux interrogations qui
sont les vote d'abord le rapport entre
la France et l'Allemagne en terme de
production agricole reste le suivant la
France c'est 19 % de la production
agricole européenne quand l'Allemagne
c'est autour de 11
% ils ont progressé mais il y a quand
même encore une marge et nous il faut
qu'on soit capable de reprendre en
tenant compte de l'environnement une
marche qui nous permett de soutenir et
de développer notre production donc on
est tous d'accord là-dessus sur la
question de
l'azote dans une zone d'excédent d'azote
structurel la vraie question qui est
posée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui tout est calculé sur la
matière organique azotée les
agriculteurs sont obligés de tout
déclarer et ils sont bloqués et
plafonnés c'est le cas en Bretagne ou
dans d'autres
endroits si on veut justement desserrer
un peu les taux qui fait que tout est
bloqué aujourd'hui et que la production
porcine je prends celle-là en Bretagne a
été diminué depuis 10 ans de près de 5 à
7 % le nombre de cochons à baissé avec
les conséquences que l'on sait en terme
industriel si j'ai donc un excédent
d'azote
organique et tout le système et c'est
logique par rapport à la Commission
Européenne j'ai de l'excelldent d'azote
organique donc j'ai dois avoir des plans
dépendage et cet azote organique doit
être calculé de telle manière qu'il ça
s'adapte au plan dépendage quel est le
problème c'est qu'en Bretagne là o on a
des zones d'excédent d'azote organique
on
achète de l'azote minéral
oui mais donc par rapport à l'Europe
pour sortir justement de
cette ce côté de cette quadrature du C
je peux pas avoir plus d'azote organique
mais en même temps je continue à acheter
de l'azote minéral qu'est-ce qu'on fait
c'est complètement schizophrène
qu'est-ce qu'on dessert comme ÉAU ben on
dit là o on a d'azote organique en
excédent on pourra le substituer à
l'azote minéral qui vient aujourd'hui
dans ces zones d'excédent et ça
permettra de libérer justement les
contraintes qui
existe mais pour faire ça vis-à-vis de
l'Europe faut quand même qu'on
s'explique peut pas faire n'importe quoi
donc on est obligé d'avoir une
déclaration sur l'azote minéral pour
voir la substitution entre l'excédent
d'azote organique et la baisse de
l'azote minéral c'est pour ça qu'on fait
ces déclarations elles sont faites par
les coopératives et les distributeurs
d'azote ça ne concerne pas les
agriculteurs mais vous êtes d'accord
avec moi qu'en Bretagne il y a des
coopératives et des distributeurs
d'azote qui sont locaux mais qu'on peut
tout à fait faire venir de l'azote
minéral d'ailleurs et là on est obligé
de de demander une déclaration sur les
transporteurs c'est pour
ça mais ça va exactement dans le sens
que vous voulez comment desserrer des
étaus comment faire en sorte qu'en
tenant compte des contraintes
environnementales on arrive à desserrer
les étaus c'est ça l'enjeu de ces
déclarations c'est pas autre chose donc
faut surtout pas se tromper sur
l'objectif je comprends j'ai bien
entendu monsieur César mais il faut que
vous compreniez que ce qu'on est en
train de faire avec l'azote total là
cette question là c'est un changement
complet d'approche qui est pas là pour
justement brider mais qui est là pour
être plus rationnel dans l'utilisation
de l'azote organique diminuer
l'utilisation de l'azote minéral et
permettre de décoincer des situations
dans lesquelles depuis des années tout
est bloqué c'est ça l'enjeu bon il y a
pas d'autre enjeux c'est pour ça que je
suis sur la ligne du rapporteur pour
dire que sur cet amendement là c'est dé
favorable parce que ça nous empêcherait
de faire ce qu'on veut
faire manque un avis du gouvernement
240tif B c'est favorable sagesse sagesse
je vous remercie très
biensur monsieur que j'ai accepté simple
une petite
rectification à faire il y a et ou au
prestataire à remplacer par et au
prestataire mais ça pose pas de çae pas
de sujet je crois c'est vous qui
défendiez
monsieuris désolé comme je vois pas
monsieur
vous acceptez chers collègues monsieur
le ministre le rapporteur moi j'accepte
la rectification elle est convenable
mais d'abord je voudrais remercier le
rapporteur d'avoir compris l'esprit mais
je voudrais profiter de mon temps de
parole monsieur le ministre pour revenir
deux mots sur la
métanisation depuis 3 ans je participe
je ne sais pas à quel titre comme
parlementaire au bureau d'abord puis
maintenant à l'office par à l'Office
Franco-Allemand des énergies
renouvelables le 14 février dernier nous
avons fait une journée entière à Paris
sur la métanisation or le gouvernement
français était représenté mais pas par
votre ministère or c'est vous qui me
paraissez détenir la vérité dans cette
affaire sur le plan technique il y a un
problème d'organisation gouvernementale
que je vous demande de voir un mot pour
vous montrer où nous en sommes en
méthanisation on a fait le point il y a
un mois il y a aujourd'hui 7240 méthan
qui fonctionne en Allemagne en France il
n'y en a pas 30 qui crachent du gaz
réellement et l'autoroute à 1 et
l'autoroute à 16 dans ma région de
Picardie sont le grand chemin de
transfert qui emmène tous nos déchets
ménagers vers la Belgique si bien que du
côté équilibre de la fermentation de nos
méthaniseurs nous donnons au belges les
capacités techniques de méthaniser et
nous allons nous en priver si nous
n'allons pas assez vite il faut être
très observateur de ces problèmes et
faire
vite merci chers collègues la parole est
à Madame primat madame prima c'est fini
monsieur
Dubois madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues monsieur le
ministre moi je je ne mets pas du tout
en doute votre sincérité par rapport à
ce qui vient d'être dit
euh par rapport au à la possibilité qui
serait offerte à travers ses contrôles
finalement de rendre un service aux
agriculteurs et et au territoire mais
permettez-moi de douter de
l'administration permettez-moi d'en
douter parce que quand on lit
l'alinéa ça ouvre tellement de porte aux
excessifs contrôles qui sont menésa dans
ces domaines je suis malheureusement
malheureusement monsieur le ministre
persuadé je dis bien persuadé que nos
agriculteurs souffriront de nouveaux
contrôles tatillons sur ces sujets et je
voudrais vous donner un exemple précis
effectivement face à l'Europe sur ces
zones donc nous avons sur ces zones
vulnérables des difficultés et que nous
sommes j'is dire prêt à payer enfin prêt
peut-être pas mais en tous les cas nous
sommes soumis à des amendes par rapport
à cela il y a donc eu des extensions de
zone vuléra récemment et dans le
département d'où je viens le département
de la Somme il y a eu un accord entre
les agriculteurs monsieur le ministre
votre administration l'administration du
pays en général pour que effectivement
il y ait un suivi sur des zones
considéré comme sensibles afin que
effectivement l'effort mené par les
agriculteurs puisse être mesuré cela a
été fait cela a été mesuré et
effectivement sur une certaine zone chez
nous au bord de l'ti il était démontré
que les agriculteurs avaient fait des
efforts et que effectivement la présence
d'azote avait diminué en tous les cas
était stabilisé dans le casadre des
extensions monsieur le ministre des
zones vulnérables alors que ce
territoire avait fait des efforts alors
que nous nous avions toute
l'administration départementale en
soutien de nos agriculteurs le préfet
coordonnateur a pris la décision
d'étendre la zone vulnérable à cette
zone où des efforts avaient été faits
par les agriculteurs où des efforts
partagés avaient été reconnus par votre
administration il n'empêche que le
préfet coordonnateur a étendu la zone
vulnérable à ce territoire où les
agriculteurs avaient fait énormément
d'efforts aujourd'hui vous vous êtes au
courant monsieur le ministre évidemment
puisquil y a des recours qui ont été
engagés naturellement jeis pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas les résultats
mais cette inquiétude elle est réelle
elle est ressentie et effectivement moi
je comprends très bien le monde agricole
face à ces obligations qui vont
permettre ne trompons ne nous trompons
pas sur le sujet ça va servir à quoi bah
à croiser les contrôles
l'agriculteur fait ses déclarations vous
faites faire des déclarations aux
transporteurs il suffira ça veut donc
dire qu'il n'y a pas de confiance dans
le monde agricole et que vous allez
contrôler à travers je diraai des
éléments croisés pour voir si
effectivement les agriculteurs tiennent
leurs engagements mais monsieur le
ministre il tiennent leurs engagements
sauf que quand ils les tiennent même
avec le soutien de votre administration
et bien il y a des décisions qui sont
prises et qui vont à l'encontre des
agriculteurs sur ce type de
sujet chers collègu la parole est à
Monsieur la
SER bon je crois que tout a tout a été
dit il me vient à l'esprit des un cas de
figure particulier nous sommes une
justeosition de cas de figure
particulier j'habite une zone
frontalière une partie importante de nos
agriculteurs sont approvisionnés livent
leurs produits à des sociétés du
Pays-Basque de Navar ou d'ailleurs c'est
pas énorme mais ça devient très
significatif et très intéressant pour
d'autres raisons bien entendu de quelle
façon par exemple cette mesure va
s'imposer à des sociétés qu'on le siège
à Saint-Sébastien à Pampelune qui vont
faire du commerce de quelle façon va-on
leur demander de faire une déclaration
annuelle je pense qu'ils ne vont pas
nous prendre au sérieux je vous livre
simplement un petit exemple qui me vient
à l'esprit sur la difficulté l'inutilité
de l'application d'une telle mesure mais
répondez précisément à ma question s'il
vous plaît merci Monsieur monsieur
lasser monsieur Mirassou
oui madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues juste don
néophit dans ce débat pas tant que ça
peut-être moi je suis surpris très
franchement et je rejoins dans mes
propos ce qui ont été tenu précédemment
par monsieur le rapporteur pour
expliquer que nous sommes en train de
travailler sur un projet de loi qui n'a
pour seul but d'aider le monde agricole
au sens large donc ça veut dire qu'il y
a l'engagement sans faille de la
puissance publique qu'il s'agisse du
reste sur le plan national ou sur le
plan européen et ce faisant du reste le
gouvernement et le Parlement
entend assurer en quelque sorte
l'intérêt général parce que personne
n'oserait faire une différenciation
entre l'évolution du monde agricole par
rapport à ce qu'elle produit et
l'intérêt général pour autant mes chers
collègues considérons quand même que en
retour le monde agricole parce que tout
à l'heure le rapporteur l'a précisé doit
aussi intégrer dans sa réflexion qu'à
l'autre bout il y a les consommateurs il
y a les citoyens il y a les habitants du
territoire qui sont légitimement en
droit d'attendre aussi et bien de
bénéficier l'intérêt général de
l'intérêt général et ça tombe bien parce
que nous en tant que parlementaire nous
sommes à l'interface de ces de mondeslà
qui sont trop souvent d'ailleurs
éloignés l'un de l'autre et moi je crois
que assorti à un certain nombre de de
mesures on peut quand même imposer par
rapport à ce monde qui n'est pas
directement rattaché au monde agricole
un certain nombre d'éléments tendant au
moins à le rassurer et en tout cas
parfois compte tenu du passé j'ai failli
dire du passif et bien lui donner
quelques garanties donc moi très
franchement je suis étoné que que ce
débat parce que chaque fois qu'on
propose sur ce sujet ou sur d'autres
quelque chose qui ressemble au début du
commencement d'une réglementation vous y
voyez des contraintes supplémentaires et
en quelque sorte une entrave au bon
fonctionnement du mondecole je pense que
vous trompez le
diagnostic monsieur Mirassou monsieur le
ministre
d'abord il y a des choses qui sont dites
par des parlementaires sur
l'administration française moi je veux
bien que on fasse des procès sur les
fonctionnaires français l'État qui est
défendu par tout le monde a une
administration donc on on respecte une
administration ils font leur travail
après il y a des directives qui ont été
signé par des gouvernements à l'échelle
européenne c'est la fameuse directive
nitrate c'est pas de la responsabilité
des
fonctionnaire je voudrais quand même pas
qu'on finisse dans ces débats à
considérer que maintenant ça va être
l'administration et le fonctionnaire qui
va devenir l'ennemi de l'agriculteur le
fonctionnaire et l'administration
appliquent des lois des directives qui
ont été signées par des gouvernements et
là soyons bien clair entre nous de
droite et de
gauche sur la question de la
métanisation si on a pris autant de
retard depuis 10 15 ans quand
l'Allemagne avait fait un autre choix la
seule question qu'on doit se poser c'est
comment on le rattrape ce retard et
comment on s'organise pour éviter de
faire les mêmes erreurs que les
Allemands qui on fait du maïs pour faire
de la méthanisation et qui commence à se
dire aujourd'hui ou là là ça va pas donc
on va pas faire ces erreurs là mais on
va quand même développer la
méthanisation ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point comment faut-il vous
expliquer que j'ai déjà dit trois fois
quatre fois la déclaration sur l'azote
minéral ne concerne pas les
agriculteurs ils sont déjà encadrés ils
sont déjà obligés de
déclarer ça concerne unique les
distributeurs d'azote minéral pourquoi
on demande cette déclaration c'est quand
même pas possible de pas vouloir
comprendre on la demande et Monsieur
quand même parce que là on la demande
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes concerné
par des zones d'excédent structurel
oui dans votre département à quel
endroit oui bon sur certain C Réal donc
on est bien sur l'azote minéral est-ce
que vous avez beaucoup de matière
organique azoté dans vot département ah
bon où ça dans les zones de montagne
dans les zones
d'élevage donc comment prenons prenons
votre exemple si laissez-moi terminer
Monsieur le Sénateur chacun a sa
parole vous avez donc dit que vous aviez
de l'azote en excédent organique bon et
vous avez dit vous-même qu'il y avait
beaucoup d'azote minéral qui étit acheté
et épendu par les
agriculteurs quel est le principe qu'on
veut mettre en place le fait qu'on
puisse substituer l'azote organique à
l'azote minéral qui est acheté ah est-ce
que c'est un mauvais principe non c'est
un bon principe et en Bretagne en
particulier si je le dis c'est parce que
les professionnels Bretons sont d'accord
quand je dis professionnels breton c'est
les agriculteurs et les responsables
professionnel quel est le principe c'est
c'est quand même pas possible de ne pas
vouloir le voir c'est de dire pour qu'on
puisse vérifier parce que devant
l'Europe on a des responsabilités la
directive nitrate c'est pas moi qui qui
l'ai signé on est obligé de justifier le
fait qu'on va utiliser de l'azote
organique en disant qu'on baisse le
recours à l'azote minéral dans les zone
d'excédent c'est quand même pas dur ça
concerne qui la déclaration sur l'azote
minéral pas les agriculteurs tous ceux
qui vendent de l'azote et par définition
ceux qu'ils en vendent ceux qui en
vendent de l'azote il la transportte
c'est pourquoi on demande la déclaration
au distributeurs et au transporteurs et
une fois qu'on s'engage dans ce procè
essus je diminue le niveau de la
pression d'excédent d'azote organique et
je remplace par l'azote organique qui
est produite par les agriculteurs
l'azote minéral qui est importé par la
France c'est pas un bon principe ça ENF
quand même et ça n'empêche et il y a
aucune contrainte supplémentaire pour
les agriculteurs
aucune qu'est-ce qui fait que vous êtes
bloqué sur cette question comment vous
pouvez m'expliquer ça donc moi je le
redis je le dis mais vraiment avec toute
la sincérité la force que j'y mets c'est
un nouveau principes donc il est
difficile peut-être à accepter à
comprendre mais il ne rajoute rien en
terme de contrainte aux agriculteurs et
il permet au contraire de débloquer des
situations où dans des zones d'excédent
on peut plus rien faire c'est bien ce
que vous
voulez donc il faut aller dans ce
sensl merci monsieur le ministre je
heureusement donner la parole je suis je
suis saisie d'un scrutin public à moins
que Monsieur le Ministre accepte que
vous ayez un droit de réponse monsieur
Deneu puisque vous avez été sollicité
allez-y mais très court monsieur laasser
pardon non moi je je suis prêt tout
acceptter mais y compris le fait que
l'on comprennent difficilement je crois
plutôt qu'on ne se comprend pas chaque
fois qu'il y a destruction d'élevage il
y a destruction d'un apport de matière
organique il y a des destructions
d'élevage partout chaque fois que dans
dans les régions la mienne notamment il
est possible de passer de l'élevage à la
céréale les gens le font pour
différentes raisons il y a donc une
fluctuation dans la pro organique qui
qui est extrêmement importante deuxième
chose dites-moi au niveau d'un stockeur
et d'un transporteur lorsqu'il fait sa
déclaration qu'il transporte que
voulez-vous qu'il en fasse si ce n'est
livré à l'agriculteur pourquoi autant de
suspici pourquoi superposition des
contrôles on va pas refaire le débat
jusque je jusqu'à pâac je trouve quand
même que je pense que ce dossier on l'a
bien compris on ne se comprend pas nous
ne sommes pas sur les mêmes conception
des pratiques économiques je trouve que
c'est vraiment encombrant pour une chose
qui évolue dans le qui évolue dans le
temps et qui de toute façon et qui de
toute façon a pour finalité le service
et les volumes donné aux agriculteurs
qui au demeurant font leur propre
déclaration voilà comment nous
comprenons ce la SER j'ai donc été
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe udi UC sur les amendements
518 rectifiés 319 rectifiés et 324
rectifiés bis je vous rappelle que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
l'avis du Gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin sera ouvert
dans quelques
instants
mes chers collègues le scrutin est
ouvert
salut
ne demande à
voter très bien le scrutin est clos
j'invite les secrétaires à participer à
procéder au
dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 162 sur les
amendements 324 379 et 518 rectifié
nombre de votants 342 nombre de exprimé
342 pour l'adoption 167 contre 175 le
Sénat n'a pas adopter ces
amendements sur je demande un vote sur
l'amendement 200 240 rectifi TER je
signale qu'il a été en accord avec la
Commission et Monsieur deut rectifié
l'avis de la commission est favorable la
viis du gouvernement et sagesse qui est
pour
merci
contre abstention l'amendement est
adopté monsieur le ministre je vous
invite à présenter l'amendement 809
rectifié c'est un amendement
gouvernemental qui vise à faire en sorte
qu'on se mette en conformité avec les
modifications qui ont été apportées dans
le cadre de la loi sur la
décentralisation sur les les les
métropoles il se trouve que les
établissements publics territoriaux de
bassin
euh sont jusqu'ici plutôt des
euh des institutions voilà
interdépartemental donc comment on
développe les métropoles c'est de
permettre des transitions pour ces
établissements afin d'aller vers des des
des des comment dirais-je des structures
juridiques de type syndicat mixte voilà
c'est pour ça que nous vous demandons de
voter cet amendement qui qui permet de
se mettre en conformité avec ce qui a
été voté dans le cadre de la loi de
décentralisation
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
vais demander l'avis de notre rapporteur
favorable je vous remercie je vais
mettre au voie l'amendement présenté par
le gouvernement qui a eu un avis
favorable de la commission qui est
pour merci qui est contre abstention il
est adopté je suis saisie de C
amendements identiques faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le premier
tombe monsieur Beaumont nétant pas là le
235 rectifier bis est présenté par
Monsieur
Billi
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre c'est un amendement qui est
repris par plusieurs
groupes vu on le constate je crois
beaucoup l'ont dit dans leur
intervention hier je crois que Monsieur
le Ministre aussi peut le constater
c'est que notre élevage est en
diminution sur le pays avec toutes les
conséquences que cela en terme
économique et en terme d'emploi donc
aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit tous que notre
pays a souvent des règlements tion qui
vont beaucoup plus loin que les
réglementations européenses donc le but
cet amendement c'est de dire que ne sont
pas soumise aux disposition du présent
titre des exploitations de B boucherie
de bovin à l'engraissement et de vaches
à l'éendes conformément à la législation
européenne donc c'est de dire qu'en
France si on
veut développer du moins reprendre un
petit peu de souffle à toute cet élevage
qui est en diminution dans ses
productions et bien de d'être moins
rigide d'utre part je crois que nous
sommes nombreux à constater et je crois
qu'il y a eu de nombreuses interventions
sur ce
sujetl pendant toutes ces années qui
montre aussi la lourdeur des procédures
d'instruction des régimes
d'autorisation je crois que monsieur le
ministre nous l'a dit plusieurs fois que
en France souvent il fallait beaucoup
plus de temps pour arriver à construire
à réaliser un investissement dans ces
domaines et que chez nos voisins donc
c'est pourquoi aussi on souhaiterait que
l'on simplifie quand même ces
procédures l'Institut de l'Élevage nous
dit qu'il faudrait 60000 places
d'engraissement supplémentairire par an
pour maintenir les capacités de
production de viande en France alors
vous voyez que c'est pourquoi cet
amendement souhaite et demande justement
que nous ayons la réglementation
européenne mais que la réglementation
européenne sur ses productions je n'ai
pas parlé des ports parce que là c'est
un autre problème mais je crois que sur
les problèmes quand même de de boucherie
des vaches à détentees c'est ce serait
important merci je vous remercie
monsieur bayli monsieur Collin le 368
rectifi bis oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à exclure
l'exexoitation de veau de boucherie de
beauvin à l'engraissement et de vache à
l'éente du régime des installations
classé pour la protection de
l'environnement on se comprend bien il
s'agit pas de remettre en cause
l'arsenal réglementaire tant européen
que que national concernant la gestion
des flux d'azote il est en effet
nécessaire de tout mettre en œuvre pour
préserver la qualité des eaux qu'
s'agisse des eau de surface ou des eaux
souterraines et bien sûr des eaux
côtières je souhaite cependant qu'un
équilibre soit trouvé entre les
pratiques agricoles et les contraintes
de compétitivité en l'application de la
directive cadre sur l'eau et plus
spécialement de la directive nitrate la
France a fixé des objectifs très
ambitieux notamment les exploitations de
veau de boucherie de beauvin à
l'engressissement et de vache àétente
sont intégré au régime de l'ICPE
alors que la réglementation européenne
n'impose pas d'obligation spécifique
pour ses éleveurs il se trouve dans
l'obligation de se soumettre à des
contrôle très pointu générant des
charges de fonctionnement conséquente et
par ailleurs la fili française de
l'engraissement qui s'appuie sur une
production de fourage sur l'exploitation
à développer des pratiques raisonnables
en matière d'épendage et donc afin de ne
pas fragiliser davantage exploitation il
convient de ne pas forcer davantage la
transition écologique dans ce secteur
voilà le sens de cet amendement
monsieur biset le 416 rectifié terre
vous considérez qu'il est
défendu il est absolument défendu madame
la Présidente mais permettez-moi de
souligner par rapport aux propos que
viennent d'être tenus par nos collègues
bailli et et Colin de de deux
choses depuis que nous avons abordé ce
projet de loi j'ai entendu des propos
qui me vont tout à fait bien j'ai
entendu le mot compétitivité j'ai
entendu le mot productivité j'ai entendu
le mot recherche innovation
simplification et bien là chich nous
avons l'opportunité de pouvoir euh je
dirais confirmer tout cela nous avons un
euh je dirais un un un péché originel en
France c'est-à-dire et monsieur le
ministre qui était député européen
pendant un certain nombre d'années le
sait mieux que quiconque c'est vrai que
nous ne savons pas faire comme les
anglosaxon c'est-à-dire faire du
lobbying avant je dirais le les
l'éclosion du une directive c'est dire
au travers des livres verts des livres
blancs nous ne savons pas travailler en
amont la sortie d'une directive et une
fois qu'elle est qu'elle est écrite et
bien la France a le péché je dirais
classique de vouloir en rajouter donc là
nous sommes dans un cas de figure
excessivement clair appliquons ce que
nous demande l'Europe mais n'en faisons
pas davantage ça c'est le premier point
la deuxième chose ça a été souligné tout
à l'heure par notre èg bai la France a
un gros souci on le voit dans les outils
de transformation viande blanche en
Bretagne et ça risque de gagner
l'ensemble du territoire national nous
n'avons plus dans certains domaines dans
certaines filières suffisamment de
matières premières pour faire tourner
nos outils de transformation et cela il
est très important si vous voulez de on
parle de réindustrialiser la France et
bien recréons des outils de des des des
outils de production dans des domaines
bien particuliers qui sont beaucoup
moins peu loin qu'on ne peut l'imaginer
à savoir les vaaues boucherie les les
bovan engressement les vaches àéente
donc voilà l'objet de de de cet
amendement on a parlé tout à l'heure de
de l'administration nous avons
l'administration la plus pertinente du
monde la plus performante du monde mais
c'est pas parce qu'elle est pertinente
c'est pas parce qu'elle est performante
qu'il faut qu'elle en fasse trop donc
voilà c'est tout euh
qui qui qui doit commander dans ce pays
gouvernement de droite ou gouvernement
de gauche passant et bien ce n'est pas
l'administration ce sont les les élus
c'est le Parlement ce sont les les
membres du gouvernement donc sans
vouloir poser deostracisme à l'égard de
qui que ce soit et surtout de gens
excessivement compétents et à l'écoute
n'en faisons pas
trop voilà un petit peu l'esprit de de
cet
amendement remerci monsieur Bizet
monsieur lasser considérez-vous que
l'amendement est défendu il est défendu
je vous en remercie monsieur le
rapporteur je vais vous demander un seul
avis sur ces amendements identiques
merci madame la
Présidente nous partageons beaucoup de
choses dans ce débat et Monsieur Buet
vient de le dire l'innovation la
recherche l'économie la simplification
mais ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que peut-être ce qui nous oppose c'est
que nous nous sommes pour la
simplification et vous vous êtes pour la
dérégulation et c'est un peu ça
peut-être la difficulté et la différence
entre nous et c'est assez fondamental
c'est assez fondamental vous
savez ça ça date pas d'hier
hein le les règlements ICPE pour les
beau vinsvande c'est pas de ce
gouvernement c'est peut-être même pas du
gouvernement d'avant ça fait des années
que ça dure et je oui mais je vais vous
expliquer je vais pardon pas vous
expliquer je vais vous répondre mais ce
que nous de ce que nous devons faire ce
n'est pas déréguler c'est simplifier et
là franchement si l'idée peut paraître
séduisante en disant B ils en font trop
ils ont trop de choses en levant cela
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut avoir comme
conséquence derrière à vérité à
l'instant n'est pas la vérité de demain
aujourd'hui dans le code il est bien
bien écrit que pour les régimes ICPE il
y a un nom a un nombre de mesures
l'autorisation l'enregistrement la
déclaration si on enlève tout cela bah
on peut faire des fermes de mil vaches
où on veut comme l'on veut sans aucune
déclaration donc c'est ça le sujet donc
aujourd'hui moi je me vois contraint de
donner un avis défavorable à ces à ces à
ces amendements on ne peut pas
totalement déréglementer et déréguler je
pense que nous avons besoin d'affirmer
ici parce que nous sommes des
parlementaires le soutien à
l'administration française parce que
nous en avons besoin nous avons besoin
sur nos territoires par contre là encore
il y a deux choses différentes le
soutien à l'administration française ça
veut pas dire le soutien parfois une
bureaucratie qui pèse un peu trop trop
non ça ne revient pas du tout au même et
c'est peut-être une conception qui vous
différencie parce que on est dans une
schizophrénie totale dans ce pays et
peut-être dans cet hémicycle on veut
moins de normes moins de régulation
moins de fonctionnaires parce que tout
ça coûte de l'argent par contre il faut
des policiers il faut des gendarmes il
faut des juges il faut des enseignants
il faut que sur le terrain on faut
surtout pas fermer des sous-préfectures
parce qu'il faut qu'elles existent mais
on nous dit toute l'année qu'elles ne
servent à rien que cette administration
nous bloque mais par contre on en veut
encore et puis après on se dit mais non
mais il y a trop de contraintes mais on
est bien content quand la DGCCRF ou
d'autres organismes viennent faire des
contrôles parce que sans les contrôles
c'est la c'est le libre cours à
n'importe quoi donc nous sommes un peu
schizophrènes c'est comme cela et après
nous avons les uns et les autres des
postures politiqu certains se disent bah
ils sont un peu plus défenseurs de
l'administration de la fonction publique
certains un peu moins certains sont un
peu plus défenseur d'un État fort
régulateur sur des fonctions régaliennes
fortes et d'autres un peu plus libéraux
ultra libéraux ou sociol-libéraux mais
peu importe on va pas s'en excuser les
uns les autres c'est le débat politique
et heureusement qu'il y a cette
confrontation mais nous ne pouvons pas
nous accepter que dans cette loi on
mette plein d'amendements de
dérégulation dont on ne sait pas quelles
conséquences ça aurait derrière et moi
j'en appelle à nous concentrer alors
c'est c'est le débat et il y a aucun
sujet nous allons voter mais j'en
appelle à nous concentrer sur
l'essentiel on passe beaucoup de temps
sur ces sujets ils sentent un important
mais je pense qu'il y a beaucoup
d'autres sujets encore plus importants
pour l'avenir de l'agriculture ça ce
sujet-là ça va pas ramener de la
compétitivité ça va pas ramener du
revenu ça va pas changer nos pratiques
culturales ça va pas nous amener à
regarder comment la formation de des
agriculteurs sera faite ça va pas nous
amener de l'installation ça et il faut
on a le débat on on en discute
évidemment mais moi ce que j'aimerait
casser vite le plus vite possible on
arrive à parler d'installation on arrive
à parler de foncier on arrive à parler
de renouvellement de génération on
arrive à parler de formation on arrive à
parler des des beau environnementaux sur
lequel on a trouvé des des équilibres
c'est ça les sujet important de la loi
d'avenir la loi d'avenir de
l'agriculture c'est une loi d'avenir qui
doit tracer des pistes tracer des
perspectives qui doivent donner des
orientation et peut-être parfois de
bonnes orientations parfois vous les
considérez comme mauvaises mais c'est le
le débat démocratique c'est le débat
politique ce n'est pas ça qui est
important mais il me semble qu'ici au
Sénat peut-être plus qu'ailleurs nous
sommes tous des défenseurs et des
promoteurs de l'agriculture et surtout
nous sommes tous des défenseurs et des
promoteurs des agriculteurs c'est pour
ça que évitons me semble-t-il et ne
croyez pas que c'est je donne quelque
leçon que ce soit évitons de nous
opposer sur des sujets qui n'en valent
pas la peine évitons de nous opposer sur
le fonctionnement et la façon dont
fonctionne l'administration française et
surtout évitons de nous opposer entre
ceux qui seraient du terrain et ceux qui
ne seraient pas du terrain entre ceux
qui connaissent de près et ceux qui
connaissent un peu plus loin parce que
nous avons tous la même la même
conception me semble-t-il il y a des
agriculteurs il y en a qui ne sont pas
mais on peut ne pas être agriculteur et
s'intéresser à l'agriculture et dans
ceux qui sont agriculteurs on peut aussi
avoir des visions différentes et donc
essayons de partager une vision commune
une passion pour l'agriculture celle de
son développement harmonieux sur tous
les territoires celle de ne laisser
aucun territoire au bord du chemin
essaie de faire en sorte que
l'environnement que les problèmes de
pollution et ben soi soi appréhendés et
que la la dérégulation ne soit pas la
règle vous savez souvent on se plaint au
niveau de l'Europe les uns et les autres
qu'il y a beaucoup de directives les
directives d'ailleurs en France je crois
qu'on l' dit hier mais on les transpose
peut-être monsieur le ministre un peu
trop vite un peu trop loin ça c'est un
sujet parle devant un spécialiste c'est
un sujet sur lequel nous devrions nous
devrions vraiment réfléchir mais souvent
l'Europe parce que c'est sa conception
nous invite à déréguler et je crois que
nos concitoyens et on le verra peut-être
malheureusement le 20 quelques mai au
moment des élections européennes je
crois vraiment que nos concitoyens n'ont
pas cette cette conception là de la
dérégulation mais au contraire veulent
des règles justes et républicaine et
équitable qui est qui encadre c'est la
raison pour laquelle moi je ne suis pas
favorable à cette proposition de
d'absence d'application du régime des
des ICPE pour les beauvin viande parce
que je pense ça serait une dérégulation
ce n'est pas une contrainte
supplémentaire elle y est c'est comme
sur les amendements supplément les
amendements précédents c'était pas une
contrainte pour agriculteurs
supplémentaires et ils le font la la
déclaration annuelle déjà donc on ne
demandait rien d'autre aux agriculteurs
c'était déjà le cas voilà donc regardons
bien les textes au fond et disons-nous
que attention la dérégulation pourrait
nous amener de drôles de choses au
détriment je pense de l'agriculture et
des agriculteurs je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre c'est le même avis défavorable
que le rapporteur pour deux arguments en
fait le premier c'est que sur cette
question des v boucherie bvin à
l'engraissement et vach chéente euh
c'est vrai que dans euh la directive sur
les établissements classés il y a pas de
précision pour ces types d'élevage mais
de toute façon il y a une directive sur
les études d'impact qui impose pour les
élevages intensif une étude d'impact
donc de toute façon à l'échelle
européenne hein ça c'est une directive
européenne donc de toute façon on sera
et on ne peut pas
imaginer que ce type d'élevage ou de
projet ne se fasse pas sans une étude
d'impact bon je voudrais rappeler
deuxièmement que ça serait plutôt la
définition d'ailleurs des des élevages
concernés et plutôt du domaine
réglementaire que du domaine législatif
donc de toute façon cet amendement s'il
était intégré dans la loi serait serait
pas comment dirais-je accepté ou
acceptable dans la mesure où c'est du
domaine réglementaire et puis un dernier
point moi j'ai engagé depuis que je suis
arrivé des évolutions sur les procédures
d'établissement classé avec ce qu'on a
mis en en place dans le la production
porcine c'est-à-dire la procédure
d'enregistrement dans le cadre des États
généraux qui ont eu lieu il y a quelques
semaines on a prévu de continuer ce
travail pour les volailles et puis pour
à terme les autres production animale
puisque cette procédure d'enregistrement
simplifie c'est bien l'objectif
les les procédures pour faire en sorte
que on est si on se situe dans des ses
à l'échelle européenne qui sont respecté
et bien on est des procédures qui
fassent en sorte qu'on
ne tout en respectant les normes on ne
perde pas le temps qui a été quelquefois
perdu par des études longues et que sur
la question de l'impact c'est le préfet
qui décide si il y a besoin ou non de
faire un ét d'impact c'est la procédure
d'enregistrement on va
poursuivre son développement dans dans
l'ensemble des productions animales et
ça fait partie des engagement qui ont
été pris aux États généraux donc ça
c'est très important très important et
je vous le dis quand même votre
majorité il y a quelques années ENF il y
a très peu de temps c'estd quand vous
étiez majoritaire il y a 3 4 ans n'avez
pas réussi à faire
bouger les procédures sur les
établissements classés ce que nous avons
fait donc là-dessus ayez aussi un peu
confiance on peut toujours aller plus
vite mais ce qui a été fait sur le port
on va continuer pour mettre en place
sans remettre en cause des règles
environnementales des procédures qui s
fie et qui raccourcissent les durées
d'instruction des projets je crois que
c'est très important de le rappeler
voilà donc je suis sur le même avis que
le rapporteur je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre je vais mettre au
voix monsieur biset je n'ai pas vu de
mince lev je pensais que le sujet était
clos oh madame la Présidente il est loin
d'être classé même si nous parlons
d'établissement classés permettez-moi
quelques quelques remarques suite au
propos tant du ministre que du que du
rapporteur monsieur le ministre vient de
parler tout à l'heure en disant ce n'est
pas du domaine de la loi c'est de
domaine de réglementaire donct mais en
tant que ministre vous pouvez quand même
donner quelques orientations à votre
administration et je suis persuadé
qu'elle pourra vous écouter voir vous
obéir c'est le souhaitable en ce qui
concerne les propos du du rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez dit
cela ne va pas amener des revenus
supplémentaire cela ne va pas amener des
installations supplémentaires je suis
désolé si vous voulez quand vous avez un
Agri culteur soit sous forme sociétaire
soit directement soit avir un double
actif sur ce qu'on appelle des ateliers
hors sol et bien le but est
véritablement pour avoir un complément
de revenu et quand en plus vous
assouplissez les procédures entre
guillemets réglementaires c'est un coût
supplémentaire en moins et donc moi je
peux pas entendre ce ce cette
explication vous dites d régulations
c'est vrai qu'on ne peut être sensible
au mots dérégulation parce que si on va
trop loin dans dans la dérégulation
c'est c'est en fait l'anarchie et en
France nous n'aimons pas l'anarchie nous
le premier monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur vous avez dit que cette
problématique ne date pas d'aujourd'hui
ne date pas même d'hier voire
d'avant-hier on est tout à fait d'accord
chaque époque a sa vérité mais on en
fait toujours un peu plus et nous sommes
en train si vous n'acceptez pas cet
amendement ces amendements d'amener sur
un plateau desps de marchés
supplémentaires à nos voisins
nous manquons de
60000 places d'engraissement dans ce
pays encore une
fois et et là moi je pense que nos amis
nos nos collègues nos les sénateurs
bretons devrai m'entendre 5 sur C nous
avons entendu dans la discussion
générale notre collègue Dominique de
Lège qui a dit très clairement dans la
filière porcine qui n'est pas concerné
par ce par cette amendement parce que
c'est une production quand même tout à
fait à part cont tenu de la nature de
ces effluents là nous ne sommes pas sur
la même nature de ces effluents il y a
un quart de siècle la France produisait
24 millions de têtes de porc aujourd'hui
entre guillemets nous en produisons 1
million de plus résultat vous avez
pratiquement 15 % d'outils de
transformation d'abattage en trop dans
ce pays je le sais malheureusement trop
bien puisque je crains que si vous
voulez dans certains départements de de
basseenormandie nous ayons quelques
souciis
nous sommes en déficit de matières
premières pour faire travailler nos
outils de
transformation alors là encore une fois
moi je souhaiterais véritablement qu'on
dépasse si vous voulez des des
problématiques droite gauche vous nous
avez beaucoup parlé des Gi2 UF en disant
laissez respirer les agriculteurs laissz
s'exprimer l'innovation les projets et
cetera là nous avons un cas de figure où
on peut le faire et si nous n'y
parvenons pas permettez-moi de terminer
par je DIRIS un propos que j'aime assez
qui était celui de d'Edgar fort
l'immobilisme avance monsieur le
rapporteur et rien ne va pouvoir
l'arrêter merci merci Monsieur biset
monsieur bailli
ouais moi j'étais assez surpris de de la
réponse du rapporteur et du ministre sur
ce sujet là aujourd'huion je crois
l'avoir dit tout à l'heure on constate
tous une diminution assez importante de
de tous notre élevage ça vient d'être
dit encore nos outils de production de
transformation qui marchent à faible
régime voir des licenciements et du
chômage dans les secteurs qui étaient
très très très agricooles et je parle de
la Bretagne en particulier alors on nous
dit vous les déréguler non on dit une
réglementation européenne pourquoi aussi
ne pas que ce soit pas celle-ci qui
s'applique et ne ne pas en rajouter donc
je vois pas en quoi vraiment on dérégule
on vous demande
simplification aussi mais j'aimerais
peut-être je le dis président de la
commission des affaires économiques moi
j'aimerais bien qu'à ce moment-là dans
les mois qui viennent on se penche à
regarder pourquoi en
Allemagne ses productions augmente et
qu'en France elle baisse il y a bien un
problème et on va pas continuer à se
faire sans arrêt sans arrêt dans toutes
nos productions agricoles sans arrêt
prendre des parts de marché par
l'Allemagne et puis à ce moment-là que
nous on vide nos campigne je pense aussi
que be la la la difficulté dans dans
tous les dossiers la longueur fond et
bien qu'on a des gens qui ne vont pas
plus loin et tout à l'heure ça été dit
encore par le collègue Bizet que cela
peut apporter des plus à des
agriculteurs qui ammettent un atelier
complémentaire monsieur le ministre tout
à l'heure vous avez beaucoup parlé de de
la métanisation je suis pas intervenu
sur ce dossier de l'azote et cetera mais
là aussi euh si on veut remplacer euh
les les engrais
importés comme vous l'avez dit je crois
aussi c'est parce que essayons
d'augmenter nos nos productions parce
que peut produire nos élevages et la
métanisation on sait bien demain ne
pourra se faire que dans des unités qui
sont quand même assez significatives on
va pas le faire dans les toutes petites
unités donc je crois que si on veut
aussi en terme
énergétique demain pouvoir que
l'agriculture y joue pleinement son rôle
ben c'est avec une présence certaine sur
nos territoires mais une présence avec
des unités quand même qui permettent une
certaine rentabilité alors c'est
pourquoi je je pensais que cet
amendement allait recevoir un consensus
un petit peu de tout le monde mais je
suis vraiment déçu que il y a des avis
défavorables de notre rapporteur et je
partage si j'ai beaucoup partager de
tout ce qu'on a fait depuis euh la
Commission et puis depuis hier j'ai
vraiment trouvé dans ses propos tout à
l'heure euh où j'ai des désaccords avec
lui et on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
je vous remercie chers collègues
dernière intervenant inscrit sur euh ce
cette explication de vote monsieur delè
oui merci madame la Présidente je
voulais juste dire à monsieur le
rapporteur que c'est pas un problème de
déréglementation nous ce qu'on veut
éviter c'est une
surréglementation donc ne nous dites pas
que nous refusons la réglementation nous
disons simplement nous voulons une
réglementation juste et équilibrée et on
a beaucoup parlé de la Bretagne monsieur
le ministre tout à l'heure je voudrais
en dire un
mot le fond de cette affaire c'est que
je vous crois de profonde bonne
volonté j'en suis intimement
convaincu
mais à
force de nous présenter des mesures dont
vous nous dites qu'elles vont régler les
problèmes auquel sont confrontés les
agriculteurs et toute la filière je suis
bien obligé de constater que ce soit
votre gouvernement ou les gouvernements
précédent que ça n'a eu pour effet que
de complexifier un petit peu plus la vie
quotidienne des agriculteurs et des
entreprise qui participe du débouché
agricole et par conséquent nous sommes
au cœur du débat c'est un problème de
confiance et plus vous en rajoutez plus
on se dit mais certainement qu'il a de
bon idées ce ministre certainement mais
comment concrètement ça va se traduire
est-ce que ça va pas être encore un
petit peu plus de contrôle encore un peu
plus de défiance et donc il me semble
que tous les amendements que nous vous
avons déposés depuis ce matin ne vont
pas dans le sens d'une déréglementation
monsieur le rapporteur ils vont
simplement dans le sens d'une plus
grande confiance entre les acteurs de la
vie économique agricole et les
administrations qui doivent les
accompagner
merci Monsieur de
leè bien je crois qu'il y a une demande
de de scrutin public en
cours monsieur le ministre vous voulez
vous exprimer je vous en
prie bon je je je sais pas dans les
explications de vote après le ministre
répond puis on on on on reprend le le
débat juste pour rappeler ce que vous
demandez c'est pas du du au ministre là
c'est c'est pas moins c'est pas nouvelle
réglementation c'est pas c'est moins et
c'est pas d'étude d'impact en gros sur
les Vau de boucherie les beau vins à
l'engraissement les vaches à
l'étente vous savez qu'on peut avoir par
exemple des ateliers en bvin en jeune
beauvin qui peuvent passer la barre des
500 des 1000 des 1000 beauins je je je
je vous le dis d'ailleurs dans le débat
avec les États-Unis les fidelotes c'est
ce qui existe et c'est ce qu'on conteste
ici en France donc prenez aussi la
mesure quand vous déposez un amendement
comme ça des conséquences est-ce que
vous seriez prêt et je prends un
sénateur ici à dessin en
normandi aucune étude d'impact sur un
atelier de jeune bovvin à 500 bovvin à
côté de chez vous moi je vous le dis à
ce moment-là parce que vous viendriez et
vous vous seriez peut-être même puisque
si on est était au gouvernement avec une
association qui consisterait à dire
c'est lamentable c'est insensé on laisse
faire n'importe quoi donc soyez aussi
vous chacun doit être
raisonnable ce que vous proposez c'est
que il y a plus de limite il y a plus
d'étude d'impact et ben je vous le dis
je prends cet exemple là à dessin en
Normandie Basse Normandie proposition
d'installation d'un atelier de 500 à
1000 jeunes beauvin je prends oui là
aujourd'hui comme ça on verrait
après voilà
donc c'est ça qui est proposé c'est
c'est pas possible c'est pas comme oui
mais par rapport à la conception de
l'agriculture et nombre d'agriculteur ça
posera un certain nombre de questions je
vous le dis quand même le projet
d'agricole à ce moment-là faudra aussi
s'expliquer avec un certain nombre de de
professionnels de l'agriculture et a
juste raison qui voudront plutôt des
agriculteurs que des gros ateliers donc
vous voyez bien que votre amendement
peut pas l'accepter c'est pas un débat
sur la simplification là c'est un débat
qui pose des questions extrêmement
importantes je l'ai rappelé
l'enregistrement il est en cours la
procédure près de 90 % des projets en
Bretagne vont passer de la procédure
d'autorisation à la procédure
d'enregistrement dcite le préfet des
côtes d'armort c'est pas rien ça va
réduire les durée donc on est bien dans
la simplification sans être pour autant
dans l'absence ça a été dit tout à
l'heure de réglementation parce que de
toute façon il y a besoin aussi de
réglementation donc on on peut pas se
faire de faux débats ou de faux procès
là-dessus et je vous le dis là sur tel
que s mis là aujourd'hui pensez et
réfléchissez un instant aux conséquences
que ça pourrait avoir des grands ateli
de fidelotte en France se ferait sans
étude d'impact je crois pas que
vous-même vous en soyez vous vous
l'accepteriez donc restons dans
l'objectif simplifier réduire les durées
respecter les règles environnementales
c'est ça l'objectif merci monsieur le
ministre après les explication monsieur
le ministre est-ce que la demande de
scrutin public est maintenue elle est
maintenue très bien
donc sur les amendements sur tous les
amendements identiques 235 368 416 552
rectifié bis je vous rappelle que l'avis
de la commission est défavorable l' viis
du Gouvernement est défavorable il va
être procédé au scrutin public dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement le scrutin sera ouvert dans
quelques
instants
merci le scrutin est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à
voter très bien le scrutin est donc clos
j'invite les secrétaire à procéder au
dépouillement
résultat du scrutin numéro 163 sur les
amendements 235 368 416 et 552 rectifiés
nombre de votant 344 nombre de suffrage
exprimé 344 pour l'adoption 169 contre
175 le Sénat n'a pas adopté monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je vais suspendre la
séance pour 5 minutes la séance est
suspendu mes chers collègues la séance
est reprise je suis saisie de 5
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune j'appelle monsieur
denu s'il est revenu non donc ah
Monsieur den est-ce que vous souhaitez
présenter le 238 rectifiataire vous
considérez qu'il est défendu ah il est
retiré très bien je vous
remercie le 294 rectifié bis monsieur
César le présent
la présidente en effet le 294 est un
amendement très important et nous
proposons de supprimer les aliné de 7 à
12 car l'état actuel du droit le champ
d'application du BA AVC clause
avementale paraît suffisant pour
répondre aux enjeux de la protection et
de la biodiversité en particulier dans
les zones sensibles voilà voilà pourquoi
nous avons dépos C am je vous remcie
monsieur César le 353 rectifié monsieur
je considère qu'il est défendu puisque
c'est le
même le 60 rectifié monsieur revet
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues
l'article 411 27 du codre rural et de la
pêche maritime prévoit la possibilité
d'insérer des clauses environnementales
dans les B deux cas de figure sont
aujourd'hui possibles les parcelles sont
détenu par un bailleur personne morale
de droit public une association agréée
de protection de l'environnement une
personne moral agréé les parcelles sont
détenues par un bailleur autre que
mentionné précédemment c'està-dire
bailleur
privé disposition réglementaire prévoit
une liste de clauses environnementales
pouvant être insérées dans le bail ainsi
l'article l411 31 du code rural de la
pêche maritime prévoit que le bail
peut-être résilié si le preneur ne
respecte pas les clauses insérées dans
le bail la possibilité d'insérer des
clauses environnemental dans les Bau
n'est pas neutre de conséquen
puisqu'elle permet la résgilation du
bail en côte défaut du preneur un
éventuel élargissement de cette
disposition entraînerait des
conséquences mal maîtrisées cette
disposition doit donc être encadré par
ailleurs l'un des piliers fondamentaux
du statut du fermage sur la liberté
d'exploitation le preneur a le choix de
conduire ses pratiques sans
l'intervention de son bailleur aussi
lorsque les parcelles sont situées dans
une zone les clauses doivent répondre au
documents de gestion officiel du bien
loué or l'égalité de traitement entre S
citoyen devant la loi les règlements
constituent un principe général du droit
que les autorités administratives
doivent respecter dans législation et
réglementation qu'ell mettent en œuvre
il est donc indispensable que les
clauses environnementales ne puissent
être inséré dans les beau quel quel que
soit le bailleur qu'uniquement dans le
cas où la parcelle serait situé dans un
zonage environnemental elles devront
être en conformité avec le document de
gestion du biené par ailleurs monsieur
le ministre je suis intervenu juste
avant l'article
1 hier pour vous demandé cétait plutôt
lié à la pêche mais c'est tout
l'ensemble du littoral eu sous les yeux
il y a quelques années des projets de
classement depuis d'unkererque jusqu'à
monts-michel pour ne parler que du
Nord-Ouest la vallée de Scine et en
différents endroits de de Vallé de scène
à travers des zones tout le littoral
zone Natura 2000 littoral ou autr or il
y a des incidences pardelà le schéma que
je vous ai demander et j'aimerais bien
avoir une réponse savoir si on le fait
je vous ai pas dit parce que j'ai pas
voulu êtreop long hier que s'agissant
par exemple deaquaculture on a diminué
de moitié en disant la production
qu'aujourd'hui la France importe 85 %
des beso de ses besoins en poisson et
crustacés c'est quand même dramatique
pour le un pays qui dispose de deuxè
zone maritime du monde je mais je vous
ai écrit enfin je sais plus si c'est à
vous ou ou ou avant il y a déjà
plusieurs mois parce que j'aiété
interrogé par la vallée de Scine tout le
long du littoral par les propriétaires
exploitant qui voulait savoir quelles
étaient les
conséquences d'un
classement de ces zones les conséquences
sur la valeur vénale des terrains et les
conséquences
parce que dès lors qu'il y a des normes
très strictes pour l'exploitation
fatalement ça a une une incidence sur le
le résultat je n'ai pas eu de réponse à
ce jour alors je pourrais vous envoyer
le double de ce courrier monsieur le
ministre pour que vous puissiez me
l'envoyer parce que c'est pas c'est pas
innocent c'est ça concerne l'ensemble du
littoral et ce qui est vrai pour le la
partie nord-ouest c'est sûrement vrai
ailleurs donc monsieur le
ministre c'est pour ça que j'ai déposé
cet amendement et que je souhaite que
vous puissiez le prendre en compte et
s'il vous plaît comme vous avez dépassé
vot temps de parole je vous demande de
présenter le 197 rectifié de manère plus
succinte le suivant oui parce que je
suis
consignataire bien écoutez il est
défendu alors il est défendu ben c'est
mieux encore
vousz c'est mieux je vous le suggéer
quand même je vais demander à notre à
notre rapporteur son avis sur ces
amendements merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le
Ministre on évoquait tout à l'heure les
taquets et les gros sujets et celui-ci
en é un le bail environnemental tel
qu'il avait
été issu de l'Assemblée nationale ne
nous convenait pas et ne me convenais
pas je considérais que c'était un
frein à la possibilité pour les
agriculteurs et notamment pour les
jeunes qui
s'installent de de de travailler parce
qu'il s limitait trop de contraintes et
c'est pour ça j'ai souhaitit que nous
réécrivions la partie sur le bail
environnemental et je pensais que nous
avions trouvé en commission un
compromis sur lequel j'avais compris
d'ailleurs que nous étions tous d'accord
ce compromis était assez clair on ne
rajoute pas des contraintes sur les
beaux
environnementaux mais en même temps on
se dit pas de retour sur les pratiques
vertueuses faut éviter les retours mais
on nen rajoutait pas plus et là vous
présenter des amendements de suppression
et moi je peux pas être d'accord avec
les amendements de suppression parce que
supprimer ce que nous avons fait
unanimement en en commission revient
mais ça c'est la vie de du Parlement et
de l'hémicycle les sénateurs sont
souverains dans l'hémicycle évidemment
mais remet totalement en cause le
travail que nous avons fait sur lequel
nous avons passé plusieurs heures de
d'audition et sur lequel nous avons bien
travaillé je voudrais simplement vous
rappeler par que tout à l'heure mon ami
Gérard B me disait mais on n'est pas
d'accord je suis déçu par ce que disait
le le le rapporteur je peux le
comprendre mais on n pas la même vision
sur tous les sujet c'est bien normal
mais heureusement mais il me semblait
mais oui oui absolument mais il me
semblait que sur six points importants
de la loi que nous avions considéré tous
comme des points importants
nous l'avions amélioré et nous avions
trouvé le point d'équilibre et le point
de compromis c'est sur la triple
performance dans les
G2 économique sociale et environnemental
et faire rentrer la partie sociale
c'était très important c'était un
compromis sur la clause miroir pour les
coopératives nous en parlerons le texte
nous convenait pas nous avons trouvé un
compromis et un compromis d'ailleurs sur
ce point qui a été validé par le par le
gouvernement en disant ne rajoutant pas
des contraintes aux aux coopératives et
ne faisons pas en sorte que dans toutes
les assemblées générales doivent tout
mettre les conseil d'administration sont
là pour ça nous avons trouvé un
compromis grâce notamment d'ailleurs à
Monsieur lasser et à monsieur Dubois sur
la compensation agricole et nous avons
avancé nous allons avancer encore et si
j'ai bien compris parce que je sais que
vous avez eu les responsablebl agricoes
que finalement les responsables
agricoles sont d'accord sur les écriture
du Sénat sur la compensation sur la
compensation agricole sur la question du
loup nous en parlerons nous avons je
crois trouvé un compromis et j'espère
que tout à l'heure demain ou je sais pas
quand unanimement nous affirmons des
choses très claires parce qu'il y a des
moments où l'intérêt général prime sur
tout le sur tout le reste nous avons
nous avions des interrogations sur le
transfert à l'ancess des AMM et nous
avons trouvé un compromis pour dire il
faut absolument que le maintien du droit
de regard du du ministre soit là et que
le ministre puisse dire des choses et là
madame Blandin a même rajouté un
amendement pour dire là encore pas de
retour en arrière sur tous ces points
qui sont à mon sens fondamentaux il y en
a beaucoup d'autres mais sur tous ces
points fondamentaux la commission des
Affaires économique sous la houlette de
de daniel Raoul a trouvé un compromis et
moi ce que je voudrais vous dire ce
matin je vous engage je nous
engage sur ces sujets-là ou après des
heures d'audition des heures de
discussion mission où j'avais compris
que nous avions un compromis je nous
engage à voter sur ces compromis sur le
reste tous les débats on a vu tout à
l'heure sur l'azot etut tous les débats
sont légitimes ils sont d'ailleurs tous
légitimes mais lorsque nous avons trouvé
un compromis je crois qu'il faut le
tenir
et je pensais que sur le bail
environnemental nous avions trouvé un
compromis que ce compromis il était
assez clair c'est de dire ne ne baissons
pas ne réduisons pas les choses mais ne
mettant pas de contraintes
supplémentaires notamment sur un sujet
que j'avais expertisé moi dans mon
département ce sujet il était assez
simple un jeune qui s'installe qui va
prendre des parcelles par-ci par là un
hectare par-ci 2 hectares par là avec
des propriétaires différents mais si à
ce jeune on lui dit ben là tu vas faire
du bio là tu vas faire ceci là tu vas
faire cela ça ne marche pas et ça c'est
des contraintes c'est des normes et
c'est des c'est des choses insupportable
et on ne peut pas l'accepter c'est pour
ça que j'espère qu'en 2è lecture à
l'Assemblée nationale l'Assemblée
nationale aura la sagesse de ne pas
réécrire en 2è lecture le texte de la
première lecture parce que il ratatine
tous les efforts qui peuvent être faits
de bonnes pratiques agricoles et
notamment chez les jeunes que pas sur
les pas pas sur les jeunes c'est pour ça
que le compromis c'était on maintient
les cas existants les cas existants on
en demande pas plus mais pas moins et on
permet en outre à tout propriétaire de
proposer un bail environnemental parce
que parce que quand même quand là on est
est tous d'accord pour les pratiques
environnementales et c'est normal qu'un
propriétaire puisse mettre un bail
environnemental mais on ne rajoute pas
des contraintes supplémentaires le débat
précédent sur la dérégulation sur les
normes sur la simplification c'est
exactement ça ne rajoutant pas des
contraintes aux agriculteurs qui
s'installent ou à ceux qui achètent des
des des des parcelles et notamment les
seules clauses admissibles seraient des
clauses garantissant le maintien des
bonnes pratiques et pas l'imposition de
normes supplémentaires c'est inscrit
c'est la raison pour laquelle je crois
que ce garde-fou que l'on a mis en
commission pendant des heures il est
suffisant et votre amendement monsieur
César et les autres amendements il le le
celui qui s'en rapproche le plus deessus
de la commission c'est d'ailleurs celui
de Monsieur de Monsieur de Monsieur rev
mais le garde-fou qu'on a vu non mais
c'est la réalité mais le garde-fou qu'on
a mis en commission euh euh paraît
suffisant et votre amendement il
supprime purement et simplement
l'extension du bail environnemental donc
moi je je suis désolé je vous demanderai
je sais pas si vous serez d'accord de
retirer cet amendement de garder la
position de compromis qui est une
position qui à mon sens a été acceptée
par la profession agricole par ceux dans
la profession agricole toute tendance
confondu qui pense que il faut quand
même mettre un certain nombre de de
barrières parce qu'on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi mais qu'on ne revient pas
en arrière qu'on en demande pas toujours
plus c'est pour ça que je aimerais je
souhaiterais que vous retiriez votre
amendement vous l'avez défendu vous avez
donné vos positions au profit du
compromis politique et professionnel que
nous avons obtenu en commission on
maintient le bail environnemental on met
les gardes-fous pas de retour en arrière
mais pas de contraintes supplémentaires
parce que les contraintes parfois et ben
on commence à en avoir un peu marre
voilà donc évidemment avis de madame la
Présidente avis de de de retrait où je
me verrai dans l'obligation de de donner
un avis déf faorable parce que c'est un
retour sur le compromis et à mon avis
sur quelque chose qui peut fonctionner
et bien fonctionner monsieur le
rapporteur j'attends de vous des avis
sur le 60 rectifié et le 197 rectifié ce
sont des avis de retrait
ou des avis défavorables celui qu'on
pourrait intégrer c'est en partie celui
de Monsieur revet mais il est alors on
pourrait rajouter un amendement le
rectifier de rédactionnel mais enfin il
est dans le texte de la commission me
semble-t-il et donc j'aimerais qu'on
puisse limiter au au texte de la
commission très bien donc retrait ou
avis défvorable pour l'ensemble des
amendements monsieur le ministre l'avis
du Gouvernement sur ces amendements sur
les amendements c'est le même avis que
le rapporteur je voulais juste rajouter
une chose sur monsieur le sénateur rev
sur la question que vous avez évoqué
déjà hier oui je prendrai l'initiative
de rencontrer le ministère de l'Écologie
et segolenne royale avec le secrétaire
d'État maintenant à l'économie maritime
pour qu'on puisse traiter la question
littorale et surtout je vous le dis la
grande question posée par l'aquaculture
ça c'est un vrai sujet on a là à
reprendre ce sujet et à remettre en
route une production et une filière tout
à fait d'accord avec vous donc je vous
ferai à vous de manière spécifique
compte rendu des rencontres que j'aurais
et des objectifs qu'on se sera fixé en
commun je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre très bien j'ai plusieurs
demande d'explication de vote monsieur
César oui merci madame la Présidente le
le rapporteur
comme le ministre vient de rappeler que
il y avait une clause et un engagement
de tous de de trouver un accord unanime
au sein de la commission des affaires
économiques je vis demander au
rapporteur si l'alinéa 10 qui dit ceci
petit à pour garantir sur là où les
parcelles mises à bail le maintien de
ces pratiques ou infrastructure est-ce
que c'est bien ça que nous avons voté en
commission c'était ça ma question et si
c'est ça si si le rapporteur le confirme
officiellement en disant qu'il maintient
donc l'alinéa 10 à ce moment-là nous
retirerons notre amendement monsieur le
rapporteur oui monsieur César je vous
remercie de votre intervention ce que
nous avons mis c'est ce que vous venez
de dire pour garantir sur là oou les
parcelles et cetera le maintien des
pratiques c'est c'est-à-dire que on on
peut on peut changer si on veut mais
voilà sur la base du volontar on
n'impose pas du plus par contre on ne
revient pas en arrière sur ce qui été
fait donc on est totalement revenu sur
ce qui avait été fait à l'assemblée qui
complexifiait et si ça vous a convaincu
je vous remercie vraiment monsieur César
de de votre position non nous avons bien
non nous avons bien travaillé tous
ensemble dans l'intérêt des agriculteurs
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
y a-t-il encore des demandes de parole
malgré cet accord monsieur denu
alors moi je voudrais me rallier à l'
vie de monsieur le rapporteur en lui
disant peut-être ne l'avait-il pas
remarqué que j'avais déjà rallé l'avis
de la commission en enlevant
l'amendement que nous avions déposé et
pour la compréhension des débats il faut
que vous comprenierz que ces gens qui
comme moi parfois nous regrettons ne
sont plus à la Commission des affaires
ch ne connaissant pas les débats
internes de cette commission nous avions
pris la précaution de déposer mais ayant
appris qu'il y avait un compromis moi je
m'y été rallié tout de suite tout de
suite alors n'insistons pas sur ce
compromis j'aurais pu vous rappeler ma
situation personnelle moi j'ai été
fermier sur 106 hectares avec 23
propriétaires et 82 parcelles
cadastrales vous voyez ce que peut
donner
l'application merci Monsieur den
monsieur
Dubois
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre euh nous avons ça a été dit par
monsieur le rapporteur nous avons
beaucoup travaillé en commission euh un
accord a été trouvé et le groupe uduic
avait retiré son amendement compte tenu
de des décisions qui avaient été prises
et du compromis qui nous paraît tout à
fait équilibré on ne tire pas un trait
sur le passé mais on en rajoute pas pour
l'avenir merci chers collègues est-ce
que je peux considérer que l'ensemble
des amendements ont été retirés monsieur
revet
oui merci madame la Présidente je suis
comme Monsieur deeu il se trouve que la
commission des affaires économiques a
été divisé en deux et que nous ne
participons pas pour un certain nombre
d'entre nous aux travaux c'est d'une
certaine façon dommage même si on
travaille bien à la commission merci de
me dire que que l'on vous manque mais
mais mais si vous voulez même si nous
faisons du très bon travail dans la
commission de de l'environnement il
n'empêche que nous avons pas participé à
cette réflexion mais ceci étant euh euh
mes collègues qui participent et je leur
fais totalement confiance euh ayant euh
pris en compte les évolutions euh qui
ont été travaillées dans la Commission
et les résultats auquel euh on est
parvenu et et monsieur le rapporteur
ayant indiqué que le seul qui pourrait
peut-être être adopté euh c'est celui
que j'ai déposé puisqu'il est très
proche du travail de la commission
je vais retirer celui-ci et le suivant
et et bien entendu s'il y avait quelque
chose on verrait plus tard mais pour
l'instant ils vont être retiré merci je
vous remercie monsieur revet toute la
série donc des amendements a été retiré
je suis saisie de six amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
monsieur César vous présentez le 313
rectifié vous êtes le premier signataire
de ce cet
amendement
merci de supprimer les années donc 13 et
14 par rapport donc aux dispositions qui
sont prises en particulier au niveau des
B voilà j'ai résumé parfaitement enfin
je sais pas si c'est parfait mais au
moins je l'ai résumé merci Monsieur
César le 534 rectifié monsieur Dubois
c'est un amendement
identique il vient d'être défendu madame
la Présidente de façon explicite
efficace rapide merci chers
collègu
monsieur le C monsieur le
oui c'est le même amendement donc ce
dispositif risque de fragiliser le
statut du fermage en permettant
d'exercer des pressions sur le fermier
qui n'est pas en position de force c'est
pourquoi nous demandons de supprimer ces
alinéas et de revenir à l'existenced la
mise à disposition au profit d'une
société objet principalement agricole je
vous remercie monsieur le le 754 n'est
pas défendu il tombe monsieur l'ABB vous
présentez le
oui madame la président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues si on a
l'impression d'avancer quelque peu
difficilement lorsque l'on entend les
débat du côté de de la droite la
transition est une absolue nécessité et
attendue par une grande partie du monde
agricole et aussi par la société civile
et par nos nos concitoyens donc cet
amendement vise à accompagné un
mouvement qui est déjà en cours donc une
un propriétaire bailleur peut lorsqu'il
a contacté un bail rural avec une
personne morale du type Gaek ou sccea se
retrouverit lié à des personnes qu'il
n'a pas choisi initialement par le jeu
des fluctuations possible dans la
composition de la structure preneur du
bail pour se prémunir de cette situation
le bailleur a la possibilité de signer
le bail non plus avec la structure
morale mais directement avec les
associés qui mettent alors le bail à
disposition de la structure juridique
qu'ils ont choisi pour l'exploitation du
bien mais le code rural ne désigne comme
structure pouvant bénéficier d'une mise
à disposition que des sociétés à objet
principalement agricoles dont le capital
doit être majoritairement détenu par des
personnes physiques or si les formes
sociétaires se développent de façon
importante dans le monde agricole il
existe aussi un développement d'autres
formes d'organisation entre personnes
partageant un projet agricole NOTAM sous
forme d'association 1901 à l'image des
AMAP ou encore les pépinières
d'activités agrices visant à permettre à
des porteurs de projets de se tester
avant de se lancer dans leur activité
agricole en production
biologique aujourd'hui la mise à
disposition d'un bail rural à une
association n'étant pas possible elles
ne peuvent être représenté que par le
biais indir d'un de leurs membres
directement preneur du bail au détriment
de leur volonté de partage collectif des
responsabilités liées à la production et
à l'entretien du bien monsieur le
ministre madame la Présidente je serais
vraiment vraiment très déçu de ne pas
avoir un avis favorable sur cette
proposition progressiste et qui suit la
volonté de la société je vous remercie
monsieur l'abbé la parole est à monsieur
Dubois pour défendre le 519
rectifié
la présidente monsieur le ministre
excusez-moi ça ça ça a un lien très
direct avec les amendements que nous
venons de de déposer précédemment et et
c'est sur la définition de la société on
parle de société à vocation
principalement agricole et nous nous
souhaitons Sanger cette phrase par les
mots à objet agricole à objet agricole
c'est dire uniquement g des sociétés don
l'objet et bien de
transformer et de cultiver la terre donc
des sociétés agricoles je vous remercie
chers collègues je vais donc demander à
notre rapporteur son avis sur ces
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la
parole madame la Présidente je vais vous
faire une réponse de
progressiste pour faire plaisir à
Monsieur Lab parce qu' faut être
progressiste comment non non non faut
pas s'en méfier parce estce que je vais
donner un avis favorable aux amendements
de Monsieur César de monsieur Dubois de
Monsieur Le Cam je vais donner un avis
défavorable à celui de Monsieur l'abbé
et le vôtre monsieur monsieur Dubois le
dernier le 519 malheureusement il tombe
mais ce que vous avez il tombe forcément
si on VO celui de Monsieur César mais ce
que vous avez ajouté à objet agricole
moi m'intéresse beaucoup et peut-être
que dans la 2è lecture faudrait voir
comment on pourrait l'intégrer dans le
dans le dans le
texte je crois que un bail rural c'est
personnel on passe un bail avec
quelqu'un avec un un agriculteur et
transférer un bail ça existe on pourrait
comprendre mais à une personne qui n'est
pas forcément
agriculteur toujours pareil par rapport
à ce qui caractérise les liges force de
cette loi revient peut-être à amoindrir
la force de l'agriculture
au profit d'autres c'est pas un procès
d'intention c'est tout simplement de se
dire que il faut que on ne peut pas
accepter un portage de de bail parce que
à l'arrivée si on laissait cela ça
pourrait présenter des risques de
détournement du statut du fermage en
fait c'est ça voilà et c'est suffisant
c'est suffisamment fragile le statut du
fermage que je vous propose pas monsieur
Lab j'en suis désolé de de vous soutenir
sur le sujet par contre je donne des
avis favorables aux autres celui de 519
tombe on regardera la suite et si nous
faisons cela je pense que nous assurons
nous assurons la
transmission de de terre nous assurons
la la qualité des des des beau ruraux et
nous évitons nous évitons d'éventuelles
dérives merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du
Gouvernement je vous
remercie très bien bien il n'y a pas de
demande d'explication de vote
monsieur
l'abbé le véritable progrès est toujours
victime d'inquiétudes qui sont qui son
qui ne sont pas forcément fondées et là
c'est véritablement le
cas la société civile l'agriculture
certes c'est l'affaire des agriculteurs
et heureusement mais l'agriculture n'est
plus que l'affaire des agriculteurs des
agriculteurs et l'affaire de l'ensemble
de la société que l' présente
ici merci monsieur l'abbé je vais
monsieur le
rapporteur je veux j'ai fait tout à
l'heure l'explication plus large je veux
répondre très précisément et très de
façon très précise et technique
excusez-moi en lisant
l'argumentaire à Monsieur l'abbé pour
bien dire que il y a pas d'opposition on
n'est pas là pour se confronter sur ces
sujets mais ce que vous proposez c'est
que le bailleur puisse non seulement
mettre le baille rural dont il dispose à
disposition d'une société à objet
agricole monsieur Dubois monsieur César
nous en sommes d'accord dont il est
membre mais également à toute
association loi 1901 dont il serait
membre et je crois que c'est là où il y
a où il y a un problème je mets pas du
tout en cause les associations loi 1901
c'est pas le sujet mais c'est un
détournement du peut sapparenter un
détournement du statut du fermage
d'abord cette mise à disposition ne ne
nécessiterait pas l'accord du
propriétaire Baur donc ça pose quand
même un problème du statut de la de de
la propriété et puis un tel montage
paraît difficilement acceptable le bail
mis à disposition d'une exploitation en
effet le bail est mis à disposition
d'une exploitation agricole ça c'est la
règle cette faculté de mise à
disposition vise à laisser l'agriculteur
libre liberté de l'agriculteur de de la
forme juridique de l'exploitation or les
associations loi 1901 ne peuvent pas
constituer le support juridique d'une
exploitation agricole et donc dans une
loi d'avenir sur l'agriculture on est
bien là pour conforter les exploitation
agricole c'est là où nous avons une
divergence je comprends la philosophie
de ce que vous dites enfin c'est pas
tout à fait l'objet de de la loi et donc
il y aurait une sorte de perte de
contrôle du bailleur sur son bien ce qui
pose qu même problème qui passerait dans
dans d'autres mains sans qu'il en ait
connaissance ou qu'il puisse s'y opposer
et donc ça ce n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas possible que il y ait un bail
qui soit donné et puis après ça change
demain le propriétaire n'a absolument
pas son mot à dire et il n'a rien à dire
sur ce que deviendrait l'objet du bail
c'està-dire ce que deviendrait les
terres donc c'est vraiment une atteinte
au statut du fermage qui me paraît
excessive je le dis sans être excessif
moi-même c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur Labé je pense que je comprends
l'intention qui vous anime dans cette
dans cet amendement mais je pense ça
peut aller peut-être ça peut-être mais
ça peut aller à l'envers de ce pourquoi
nous travaillons depuis des jours et si
j'ai bien compris nous allons continuer
au rythme où nous allons pendant des
jours c'est de conforter l'agriculture
le statut de l'agriculteur et les
exploitation agricole voilà merci
monsieur le rapporteur je vais donc
mettre au voix l'amendement 313 rectifié
le 534 rectifi et le
599 qui sont identiques ils ont reçu un
avis favorable du rapporteur et un
invvit de sagesse du gouvernement qui
est
pour merci qui est contre abstention ils
sont
adoptés monsieur le je suis désolée
monsieur Labé le votre tombe et celui de
monsieur Dubois
également monsieur duboisb votre
amendement est tombé là vous n'avez plus
la parole madame la Présidente mais j'ai
noté avec beaucoup d'intérêt les les
propos tenus par monsieur le rapporteur
pour la seconde lecture très bien merci
bien j'ai un à l'article 4 toujours un
amendement 177 il est présenté par
Madame Blandin madame la Présidente vous
avez la parole merci chers collègues
c'est le dernier sur le bien-être
animal cet amendement porte sur le cadre
qui s'offre au mutation de l'agriculture
et de la transformation des aliments la
transformation des produits est en
adaptation permanente sous la pression
de de goût ou de besoins nouveaux
besoins souvent créés par la publicité
et la grande distribution ainsi que sous
la pression des marchés car les matières
alimentaires restent Etas des
marchandises soumises à spéculation la
science ouvre des possibilités sans
cesse renouvelé de modifier alimentation
reproduction forme productivité des
animaux d'élevage mais il doit y avoir
des limites éthiques ce n'est pas parce
qu'on sait le faire que l'on doit le
faire même si cela rapporte plus
d'argent à certains qui au passage sont
rarement les éleveurs eux-mêmes le texte
qui nous est proposé est équilibré il
évoque la qualité des produits ce n'est
pas parce que l'on sait produire du bœuf
aux hormones que l'on va en produire au
risque de perturber le métabolisme des
consommateurs et celui des enfants
aménagement du territoire ce n'est pas
parce qu'il serait plus simple de
cultiver et élever en pleain qu'on va
abandonner les paysans des montagne
maintien de l'emploi en milieu rural ce
n'est pas parce que des professeurs
Nimbus veulent appliquer les recettes du
BTP ou de la science-fiction aux étables
qu'on va faire des usines à mil vaches
et transformer nos campagne en parc
d'attraction le cadre proposé est donc
vertueux mais il y a un oublie le
respect du bien-être animal faute de
cette mention nous n'aurions aucun outil
pour décourager les pratiques de
mutilation ou
d'immobilisation favorable à la
production mais génératrice aujourd'hui
de souffrance et demain de misise auorme
douloureuses et coûteuses voire de
faillite quand tomberont les règles de
Bruxelles de plus un cadre vertueux en
matière de bien-être animal est est une
protection pour nos éleveurs car c'est
bien
l'agroalimentaire qui tire les prix vers
le bas importe n'importe quoi se moque
des conditions d'élevage au Brésil ou à
Taïwan et ruine les producteurs de nos
régions vous avez tous vu l'émission de
télévision qui nous montrait les
ateliers farmort d'une célèbre
coopérative et les poulet lowcost
importés du Brésil et de Taïwan je vous
remercie madame la Présidente tu vais
demander l'avis de notre rapporteur sur
cette question le 177 merci Madame La la
la présidente madame
Blandin le bien-être animal a été
rajouté dans la loi dans les dans les
objectif de la politique agricole
générale c'est la première fois qu'il a
été fait et sur ce sujet tout le monde
était d'accord par contre je ne peux pas
être d'accord d'en faire un objet
spécifique parce que alors après on s'en
sortira pas et de le mettre dans le Code
Rural ce n'est pas possible donc je
pense que on peut dire qui peut le plus
peut le moins ou qui peut le moins peut
le plus mais c'est inscrit dans le
premier article dans le cadre de la
politique générale agricole et je ne
crois pas je ne pense pas qu'il faille
en faire un objectif spécifique je
comprends que vous présentiez votre
votre amendement mais je vous demanderai
de bien vouloir le retirer au quel cas
je me verrai contraint de sinon je me
verrai contraint de donner un avis
défavorable oui pour la Pol l'écriture
dans la politique générale et pour en
faire une orientation non pour le mettre
de façon à faire un objectif spécifique
de la politique agricole parce que ce
n'est pas un objectif spécifique de la
politique agricole on pourrait prendre
plein d'autres plein d'autres secteurs
de la société où on pourrait en parler
donc je pense qu'il limitonsnous et
c'est la première fois que ça y est à
l'inscrire dans la politique générale et
ça sera une grande avancée déjà que nous
aurons sur le sur ce sujet je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur l'avis
du Gouvernement sagesse M avis que le
rapporte sagesse ou même avis que le
sagesse sagesse sagesse d'accord merci
très bien Madame Blandin madame la
Présidente vous souhaitez répondre une
explication de vote ben écoutez je vais
le retirer pour faire gagner du temps je
ne suis pas assurée d'avoir une majorité
mais monsieur Guillaume a laissé passer
la dernière occasion de soigner son
karma vis-à-vis des espèces
animales merci madame la Présidente pour
ce retrait voilà pour l'examen de ce
projet de loi sur l'avenir de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation et de la
forêt examinz en première lecture par le
Sénat ce texte a été adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale au mois de janvier
dernier et l'examen devrait se
poursuivre au Sénat ce weekend a priori
l'ordre du jour est ouvert jusqu'à
samedi soir vous pouvez toujours revoir
la séance sur notre site sur
publusenat.fr on reparle bien sûr de
l'agriculture dans 24h Sénat 19 présenté
parphine Girard très bonne journée sur
les chaînes
parlementaires